approchez vous s'il vous plaît s'il ya
le merveilleux on laisse passer parce
que le plus important dans cette
histoire ça va l'image l'image qu'on va
donner nous depuis 7h30 les gilet jaune
de dole sont sur le pont au tour de
fabrice la gueule animateur d'un
mouvement dont il soigne l'image qu'ils
souhaitent solidaire et respectueuse
pour éviter tout dérapage de choisy à
rochefort-sur-nenon six à huit barrages
filtrants ou bloquants de courte durée
se sont ancrées avec des manifestants se
disant citoyens plutôt que politisé ya
pas de politique ses citoyens ce n'est
qu'il n'ya pas voyez on n'a pas marqué
cgt a pas marqué partie droite parti de
gauche il n'y a rien c'est on est tous
solidaires
c'est pour nous pour nos enfants
il y en a mare aux canards poules il
faut que ça change kia jordi ya des
taxes il y en a beaucoup trop
moi je suis dans une famille il ya
quatre enfants et ma mère s occupent
tout seul de nous on a on n'a pas besoin
de taxe en plus qua non politisée
pourtant leur leader ne cache pas ses
préférences libéral lui dont la
contestation dans la rue n'est pas la
culture c'est pas du tout ma culture je
dirais que c'est tout le contraire c'est
la première fois et là c'est pour monter
de mobilisation c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
qu'on va essayer très rapidement de
faire évoluer notre mouvement qui soit
après force de proposition les médias
sont là et les manifestants toujours
prêt à entonner la marseillaise mais
tout contrôler reste compliquée sur le
rond-point de rochefort un automobiliste
excédé a forcé le barrage tout le monde
pense à l'accident mortel en savoie je
suis un petit peu abasourdi par la
nouvelle donc de l'accident savoir et il
faut pas la journée n'est pas finie
donc il faut vraiment qu'on reste sur
nos gardes et puis qu'on soit très très
vigilant très vigilant
fabrice la gueule à essayer de préserver
une image positive avec l'idée
d'inscrire ce combat dans la durée